hi guys it's cheryl last time i cooked
for my mother-in-law the rice is not
cooked well completely it's my turn to
cook for my father-in-law some authentic
mexican food
oh
we're going to be making asada with some
tortillas and some rice as well
you're going to do right
good luck thank you
look he he was super supportive he was
like i'm going to do well that just puts
a lot more pressure because what it
doesn't turn out okay you're starting an
authentic mexican barbecue yes i am
these have to turn white
let's start with this rice right here it
does look like a lot but if i know
anything about rice's it might be small
but it's mighty
do i wash the rice
yes
i think that's too big
that's a lot okay
[Laughter]
my father-in-law because i care
why you sound so nervous
okay
first step you have to let the water
warm
there's no water no that's how you make
it oh that's a different way
well i think it has a lot of oil you
have to keep moving it because it's
gonna
burn gets like brown and you have to be
even everything my father gave me this
because he saw that i'm a little nervous
just cool be down
how do you feel so far i think it's
going pretty well it's a lot more
supportive than i thought it was going
to be which is great right now we're
doing the rice and now we're about to do
that oh and the chili's as well
let's go could you explain to me what
exactly we're doing right here you said
to clean the grill
just give them
yeah yeah
[Music]
huh
that was just one onion bro
we have some marinated carne rancher
marinated that
a little bit ago what should i use my
hands straight
oh yes okay
yeah isn't that even gonna
feed on the
[Music]
now i want to make your life easier oh
thank you
did the rice burn
back to the meat
you have my dad cooking the meat for you
no i'm not i'm not
no
we're gonna put the chili this is
something that like i realized that i
guess mexican culture does that like
haitian culture doesn't do we don't
grill this stuff this is cool though
we grill everything everything all the
vegetables so how do you know when the
onions are good i just know i don't know
you just know they have to be like soft
we have to be like
harder
[Music]
all right
all right
i don't know if it's
survived it's her bike it's got some
character you know
some crunchy so one thing i learned from
cheryl's video when she was cooking for
my mom
is if you don't want to cry cutting
onions please how much i love my
mother-in-law
washer
have you been flipping them with your
hand
no that's how the real mexican way oh is
it yeah okay let's see
come on
my grandma could do this faster
your grandma's been used to this fire ow
oh no
good job
[Music]
is my food really hard happy
who takes whatever
so what do you think about your
son-in-law cooking for you for the first
time i think it's a nice experience for
me because
i was really hungry
it's very good
we're gonna give you 11.
frijoles
that's a very
small flavor man
i'm gonna give you
eight because uh
i don't like uh too much
onions
the jalapeno
very good out there you see the the rice
there's the rice
great job the rice is gonna be nice
give you a nice well thank you alvin for
for cooking for me
and i hope this is not gonna be the
the last time okay i'm gonna bite her
for the next time
[Music]
do
[Music]
you